hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm still trapped in this closet I'm
trapped in no I'm not even gonna start
singing that one so ah make as many
Joker's you won I'm coming out of the
closet hello
nice man he's still there I just feel
like screaming randomly he seems to be
gone but then I've been mistaken before
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha that is a big
big patch ha I am wimpy slow moving - ok
someone is throwing bits of meat at that
door I should move on the Moose man
slapping the door with this dong it's
log canoe the Baron thank you for
important news is that Stewart had
Stewart needs a different way informing
him at the plague breaking out in the
areas of the castle that you are
responsible for quarantine ok I can do
that one disappointing the Bears are
will don't look missed a punishment and
they need hardly remind you what that
entails perhaps feed the key to a pool
feed the key to wait what about a key
lock the door to the upstairs and
prevent anyone include feed the key to a
pig to prevent one of your more rash
staff members from doing something they
will undoubtedly regret
hey the key to a pig why would they feed
a key to a Oh was it haha so slow
can't find me I'm in a closet entrapped
into a clock now did anyone actually see
the full be full of it full music video
that song where I was like it was like
the whole song with some weird rambling
of thoughts connected together we're
like guys went gay and he went to his
grandma's she had a spatula
did he just bash open that and turn to
mush I think he did I fell down and
there's big screaming in my ears
oh man tell me I'm not the only one
thinking of amnesia machine for pigs
right now that seems like the utmost
logical conclusion oh man there anything
in here
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just good they won't stop screaming
alright then try to carry on the note
said feed the key to a pig so I'm
guessing oh shut up piggies oh shut up
pig it's just so powerful
I'm definitely everyone's got to be
thinking I needs your machine perfect
right now right now I gotta get it out
of the pig can I use it this way so
that's fine in it and there was a saw
those a saw in the other room maybe if I
saw them open oh oh pile up the piggies
at the front door I can't even use my
lantern oh oh I'm gonna crawl bar to
piss out of your piggies anyway maybe
the chipper nothing inside sits egg oh
it's so gross I've had the key is that
the only thing in here there's something
one of the other piggies oh oh I want to
get out of here I want to get out of
here so bad this is the stuff of
nightmares
this is definitively the stuff of
nightmares
oh my god please stop good god oh that
was so wrong man seriously everyone in
these your machine for pigs um the
reason why they picked the name a
machine for pigs in case you didn't know
was because they wanted a name that
conjured up a really horrific image in
your mind and when you think of a
machine that is intended for pigs
almost everyone thinks immediately of a
slaughterhouse and a machine that will
kill piggies as they squeal for their
lives so it conjures up a pretty
horrific image play click got it
uh-oh I'm breaking quarantine what you
gonna do what you gonna do what you
gonna do about it what you gonna do what
you gonna do after I thought you ain't
gonna do nothing okay so
I miss some I know I'm good okay ah I
don't know if it was the combination of
seeing the statue right there in the
door slamming but I'm not sure which one
actually made me jump it's locked again
but I got to find another key in one of
these new mannequins yeah huge firkin
yeah juice Birkin oh hello
been my existence in this place as a
curse but I have not lost her
my body is flagging and my mind is
increasingly prone to despair I've
encountered many obstacles that have
seemed insurmountable but events that
make me believe I'm not alone down here
still my results I must remember when
things seem hopeless to look to powers
and explanations beyond myself for
instance as I entered this chamber the
door behind me shut and locked the door
on the opposite end of the chamber was
also locked our amount of force seemed
able to budge either of them I attempted
every conceivable method of opening the
door I tried to pick the lock with
shards of stone
I threw heavy objects of the door and I
ran my shoulder into a dozens of time
all Hall despair overwhelmed me and I
sat down in the mint then the key
required to open the far door from above
as though God had shown pity upon me I
know that this key opens the door which
will lead to the castles entrance hall
and beyond this entrance hall lies the
chapel where I may escape this place and
transcend this nightmare okay all right
so basically I have to act like a douche
to try to get this door open and then a
Keys gonna fall from the ceiling or
maybe the key is just up on the ceiling
that seems more likely
hang on I think I'm onto something
already I'm so smart
ah maybe I'm not that smart wait hang on
it's cramming shoulder on filled with
despair
ah anything gift from the heavens I
guess not
and let's see what I can see up there
okay there's two boxes and a a big box
two boxes and a big one I don't see
anything that I could stack to get up
there so looks like I'm kind of on my
own in that regard I'm guessing that the
door locked behind me quite thoroughly
okay so I have to get this that was easy
I am so smart that Ulrika is dumb man
kliklak done and done
I am lip house I am boughs oh what's
under the stairs I wonder I wonder I
wonder three times I wondered hoping
that there would be some treasure
underneath here but there is not all
there is a little bit of oil I guess
it's something I got plenty of oil then
again I haven't been using my lantern as
much as I should have
man don't know where I got an accent
from but let's continue forward
so far I've been able to conquer this
and this custom stories rather strange
logic what I've been doing okay hello
hello guv
what's in here right so the entrance
hall oh boy I'm finally gonna find my
way out of this nightmare hopefully not
just yet because it said it was gonna be
a two to three-hour custom story I mean
I know our mom and damn needs your pro
and all that but it cannot end so soon
oh I can't use my lantern what have you
got for me what have you got for me
my visions a little wonky I am about to
fall over oh goody everything's on fire
now
[Music]
why I should know better than to ask why
Oh everything's better now good and
there's a note here that's fantastic
I just decided to freak out for a second
there but in the end I'm against my
intuition seems to have forsaken me the
ones compassionate higher power has
abdicated I'm alone here and I have no
help to myself for an eternity I have
now labored in this labyrinth in castle
tracking over already cross regions
countless times uh-huh I feel I cannot
rely on my mind for sound reasoning aha
I occasionally have lapses in
consciousness which made me feel as
though I'm regressing into darker colder
worlds even lonelier than my current
location aha I cannot hope for the God
that was once so benevolent to assist me
and now seem certain that I cannot
escape okay I'm not beginning to think
of some twist in this that I am actually
Ulrich and this is just me trying to
find a way out of the castle again I'm
in some weird purgatory okay so oh wait
hey I was just rude there I guess I get
to go a new way now and I'm I'm like
damn to wander this castle over and over
and over repeating the same actions
except that I see
my back
[Applause]
[ __ ] you I don't know how I trapped him
behind that but
so long away I got a run okay here we go
oh come on I knew it was gonna make me
run you [ __ ]
I'm Parker level extreme can't throw
maybe every meet you bro baller chapter
two owls all chapter one how many
chapters are there right now rip you
like hi I'm so dedicated to my eternal
quest to smash all these things that I
actually stopped while I was being
chased
oh look it's a way out my hang-up oh
look it the way out freedom ah freedom I
thought it was gonna close on me freedom
freedom oh I can actually go outside he
kidding me oh I thought for sure it was
gonna slam on me while I'm going back
inside
screw that I'm not going free whoa hang
on wait wait wait wait ah
[Music]
that doesn't sound very Christmasy
[Music]
that actually sounds kind of awful and
horrifying
[Music]
yeah I wish I didn't do that I now
regret that decision
and this place is gigantic there's a lot
of places to be here oh shut up
haunted Christmas music ah I feel
sometimes yeah yep
the only an idea that it's clear to me
is that the chapel is my Redemption no
this chapel what could be present in
this place instead of God why do I feel
compelled forth why am I so certain that
my salvation lies that because you've
done this ten thousand times before and
I'm actually you but I'm not you you're
me no I'm you but that's just it I'm not
you yeah you're me anyone Will Sasso
well MADtv you all don't know art never
okay so I've been wandering around
awhile I'm just trying to get an
exploration of this place before I
settle down that they tremble before
human that in the name of Jesus Christ
they can be driven out I do not doubt
the power of God but I have come to
doubt this Craig the man for there is a
great evil among us a demon has
infiltrated I hold his chaplain
possessed following will him six months
ago he was preaching to an awful
audience in the chapel now he preaches
only to himself in the foul lists of
terms you have ever heard
it was slow to begin with he was simply
more reserved in his preaching and in
his disposition to the rest of us but
then his habits changed he was eating
less sleeping less and kept all to
himself outside of services before long
he had removed himself entirely from the
rest of the world they locked himself
into his quarters and it made
no one we had to do some God knows we
had to do some okay I'm tired of that
tire blah blah three broken through the
door I'm not skillful enough to quilt
father William gazing at us through
gaping holes where his eyes should have
been his skin was pale as he'd be
drowned man this would have been a long
time if I'd kept that voice up then he
attacked us strength unlike anything
we've ever seen Luke was cut in two with
his English wiping Phillips head was
snapped back with a short twist I was
spared though I know not why he took his
boils to the chapel and that is where he
has remained the machinery for the door
for it is run mechanically has been
turned off the chain securely pad locked
in the key thrown over the rails and to
the sewers he hasn't broken through yet
what have we done to invite such evil
onto this holy ground what will become
of us okay
that was a long way to go to say there's
a monster in the chapel he could have
just said there's a monster in the
chapel don't go in here you dumbass so I
need to get into the chapel for I am
dumb yeah I am dumb the unintelligent
flows through me like a river okay I'm
done with the southern baptism preacher
person so I'm all done for ask apart
thank you all someone for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next part
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]